Hello Freak bitches.
You don't think of that as being a
stress like they think of stress as
being bills.
They think of stress as being traffic,
no stresses,
every,
all those things are stress,
relationships,
friendships,
work conflict.
When you're at work all day and you hate
your job,
that stress,
that is stress that grinds on you.
That feeling like when you get out of
work at the end of the day and you have
that weight lifted off your shoulders,
that means you're in a bad job.
You gotta figure out a way where you
don't have that.
If it's possible,
if it's possible,
find that way.
That was me 10 years ago.
I was a municipal tax assessor in,
stayed in New Jersey.
Amazing.
It was the just saying all those things
together make me want to fucking jump
off a roof on Friday.
I would literally get depressed on
Friday because I knew Monday was coming.
Yeah,
I know that feeling.
It was fuck.
It was God damn hell,
but I was making a shitload of money.
My mom was so proud of me.
I had the four o one k and the six weeks
off vacation I was living the American
dream.
I fucking hated myself.
I sat around,
I remember this was the turning point
for me.
I sat around a boardroom table and I was
a lot younger than my closest peer and
I'm looking at all these older dudes and
we're all sitting there and suits and
like all were so fucking important,
you know,
being those dickheads and they're all
overweight,
they're all,
they all have red faces and they're all
talking about how they're going to
fucking,
you know,
sneak off to the bar before they go home
because they don't want to deal with the
fucking family and the kids and all the
fucking bullshit.
Like I get it the fuck out of here.
I have to get the fuck Outta here,
where I'm going to fucking die like
this.
I got to change my life.
And that's what we did.
And I kind of threw that away.
Resigned from the position,
took the job as the strength coach at
team quest up in the Portland,
Oregon,
moved across the country for fucking
minimum wage to clean toilets and left
that job behind.
And I fucking loved it.
I loved scrubbing disgusting,
Shitty Gym Mats at five o'clock in the
morning and not sitting in a beautiful
corner office,
you know,
for x amount of dollars per year.
Because I was,
I was doing what I loved and I gave
myself the opportunity and a chance to
do something with my life and get leery
of distress.
I think that's why I'm kind of veering
off it.
That's what it was talking.
I was so stressed out and I was riding
my bike and fuck,
I remember it was freezing cold,
fucking raining.
And I'm riding my fucking stupid bike
cause we only have one vehicle.
You and my wife had to go fucking work.
I'm riding my fucking bike six miles to
the gym and I fucking loved it.
It was such a pure,
crisp,
cold morning and it was just so alive in
life,
you know?
And it was,
everything was brand new again.
And I was in my mid twenties at that
point,
mid later twenties.
At that point.
It's fucking cool shit man.
But he gave me the best advice ever,
uh,
that ever got in comedy.
And I,
I talked about this in my act a little
bit,
like I tell the story,
but we were hanging out after we did a
show one night in Cleveland at the,
at this big amphitheater.
And after the show I'm talking to these
two girls and they're like,
you're so funny of that.
And I'm like,
once you come back to the hook towel,
yeah,
come hang up.
Dave might stop by.
You know,
I was trying to say that.
Yeah,
I was trying to pick up these chicks.
He actually wasn't gonna stop by the
imagine if you were in the middle of
boner and she heard Dave's voice and
she's like,
get off me.
Yeah,
exactly.
Imagine me.
His cock blocking anybody standing in
the living room.
I'm Rick James Bitch.
Oh my God.
Is it him?
I need a meet him.
He's not going anywhere.
I'll come in 30 seconds.
He was awesome.
No rape.
He was an awesome wing man cause he was,
he was,
he's married and he was like a great
dude about it.
He was just like,
you know,
he would sit there and like talk to you,
with the chicks and then like he'd peel
off and then you'd be there with the
checks.
Man,
it was fucking beautiful.
And the chicks would go,
you must be special.
Oh Dude.
Well they also just saw you open for
dude,
it was so,
oh look at you.
You're glow.
There's really,
it was nice.
It was nice.
It was really nice.
So I was talking to these two girls
after one of the shows in Cleveland and
uh,
and I'm like,
come back to the hotel and they're,
they're being wishy washy.
And I'm like,
all right,
whatever.
And they take my number and I go
backstage and I'm bitching to Dave and
the,
the tour bus driver about these checks.
And I'm like,
you know,
they fucking just being on wishy washy
and I don't know this and I don't know,
it's just annoying.
Just fucking hanging out.
If you're going to hang out and the bus
driver goes,
Joe,
I'm to tell you what you need to do,
man.
You need to walk up to that girl,
look her dead in the eye and say,
do you want to suck my Dick or not?
Right.
And I was like,
terrible advice.
I was like,
okay,
okay.
And uh,
and I was considering it for a second
and then Chappelle goes,
don't do that shit man.
Don't do it.
You're going to fuck around.
Joe.
You're going to get famous one of these
days.
10 years from now,
that bitch will be on hard going,
Joe Derosa told me to suck his dick and
Cleveland once.
That's how I grew up.
I mean,
I would go out a lot of times during
school and I'd just go up,
sleep on the mountain,
come back,
do chores,
milk cows,
go to school,
you know,
go to football practice,
go home,
do chores,
go up on the mountain,
sleep on the mountain,
come back home.
I mean,
that was kind of how,
how my brothers and I grew up and
it's just,
I mean I just have a yearning for the
wild.
I mean there some of the coolest
experiences that I've had in life have
been when I'm by myself and go and do
something totally random that,
that,
that nobody else would really even think
about.
I say,
shit,
I shouldn't say nobody,
but it's like,
you know,
in college I'd drive home two hours to
my folks' house,
then I drive another hour up to the
canyon.
By the time I get to the trail head,
it's 11 o'clock at night,
hike in for three or four hours,
find some more sleep,
get up on top of the mountain.
And I'm sitting there as,
as the sun's coming up and three
wolverines come up,
you know,
and circle the lake and it's like back
then,
you know,
in the,
in the 90s there weren't wolverines in
Idaho.
There weren't supposed to be anyway.
I mean I was one of the very first or
very few to actually see wild wolverines
in Idaho.
And it's like,
had I not been there by myself,
experienced in that,
in that canyon,
you know,
if there's other people or other things,
those wolverines might not have been as
comfortable,
you know,
but because I was there by myself and
I'm the only one there looking down over
it,
I had that.
And there's,
there's a lot of opportunities like that
that
when you have someone else there,
you're focused on the group,
you know what you're focused on,
your conversations,
your buddies,
your friends and everything.
You're not,
you're not really tuned in to what's
around you.
You're not tuned in to your
surroundings.
And so there's certain things that I
think you miss out on when you've got
other people there.
And it's not that I don't enjoy that
sometimes,
but I feel like when I'm there,
like there's a connection,
you know,
there's a connection to the land,
there's a connection to the environment,
and,
uh,
you know,
you could bring all of into if,
if you're,
if you're a Hippie,
you know,
tree hugger,
Voodoo type person,
you can bring in the nature and the gods
and all that kind of stuff into the
whole element.
But that really and truly is what is
what it is,
is you're out there with no one but
yourself and God and his creation.
I mean,
that's it.
It's all surrounding you.
Yeah.
And being like that deep in nature where
you're actually a part of it because
you're not,
you're not talking to anyone.
So there's no,
there's no conversations going on in
your conversations there just with
myself.
But you know what I'm saying?
It's like you don't,
there's nothing,
no anchor that brings you back to
civilization.
You just seeing wild shit.
You're just seeing wildlife.
You're seeing animals that would exist
that way regardless of whether or not
you were there or not.
Yeah.